y en directo a Vamos hasta México
culminó la segunda fase de la mesa de
diálogos entre el gobierno de Colombia y
la guerrilla del ejército de liberación
nacional con avances de Cara a una
eventual cese el fuego tras esta ronda
El Ejecutivo de Gustavo Petro reconoció
el estatus políticos del eln como una
organización Armada Rebelde para ampliar
esta noticia saludamos en la capital
mexicana nuestro corresponsal Mario
carbonel Mario muy buenas noches
háblenos sobre las conclusiones de esta
ronda por favor
Hola qué tal Así es se firmó ya lo que
se dio en Llamar el acuerdo de México
que incluye básicamente seis puntos que
tienen que ver para construir esta Paz
tan anhelada el primero es la
participación ciudadana es decir
garantizar mecanismos incluyentes y
dinámicos para la participación de la
sociedad en esta construcción de la paz
el segundo tiene que ver con la
democracia democracia para la paz que
implica Pues fomentar que las decisiones
de la ciudadanía se traduzcan en
políticas públicas el tercero es
transformación para la paz esto tiene
que ver con el desarrollo de las
comunidades y también la revisión del
modelo económico el cuarto punto tiene
que ver sobre las víctimas y la
reparación integral ya sea colectiva o
individual estos puntos Fueron acordados
por ambas partes y hay dos aspectos
fundamentales el primero ya lo decíamos
es garantizar la participación de toda
la sociedad Y eso será el corazón de las
negociaciones y el segundo y también no
Por ello menos importante es el cese al
fuego lo dijo Pablo Beltrán en su
intervención la intención es en esta en
esta nueva agenda Se abordó el primer
paso hacia un cese al fuego que será
bilateral nacional y temporal en sus
intervenciones también el jefe
negociador por parte del gobierno OTI
Patiño hizo mención de que se le entregó
a la vicepresidenta Francia Márquez un
documento de asistencia humanitaria en
las regiones más afectadas de la costa
Pacífico ahí donde se encuentran
comunidades negras comunidades indígenas
que han sido las víctimas que han
resintido los efectos de este conflicto
armado desde luego uno de los puntos más
importantes es precisamente el fin del
conflicto armado que es parte también de
estos puntos de esta nueva agenda y
llama la atención que incluye la
resolución de la situación jurídica de
los integrantes del eln así fue como en
el colegio de San Ildefonso se firmó
esta agenda Mario Qué se sabe sobre las
próximas rondas de negociaciones
se ha confirmado que será en Cuba en las
próximas semanas no se tiene aún
definida la fecha exacta pero será en la
Habana la continuación de estas
negociaciones pero ya se llevarán a cabo
con base en esta nueva agenda que se ha
definido aquí en este segundo ciclo de
negociaciones en la Ciudad de México
tocará ya en la Habana poner en práctica
esto que han acordado y sobre todo lo
han dicho también
en cuanto al cese al fuego que será uno
de los puntos más importantes porque es
una exigencia de la sociedad así lo
definió OTI Patiño y también hay que
comentar que se hizo énfasis en que
habrá acumulación de experiencias
previas Como aquella tregua de 2017